>> WHAT MESSAGE DOES IT SEND TO
VLADIMIR PUTIN THAT THE
UNITED STATES HAS NOT FULLY
IMPLEMENTED SANCTIONS TO COUNTER
NON-RUSSIAN CYBER ATTACKS?
>> I BELIEVE PRESIDENT PUTIN HAS
COME TO THE CONCLUSION THERE IS
LITTLE PRICE TO PAY HERE AND
THEREFORE I CAN CONTINUE.
IN FAIRNESS, YOU CAN'T SAY
NOTHING HAS BEEN DONE BUT IT
HASN'T BEEN ENOUGH.
>> WE ARE LOOKING AT A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT THINGS THAT WE CAN DO
TO PREVENT THIS FROM HAPPENING.
AND WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
BE TOUGH ON RUSSIA MOVING
FORWARD, JUST AS WE HAVE BEEN IN
THE FIRST YEAR.
>> Bret: ADMIRAL ROGERS ON
CAPITOL HILL TALKING ABOUT THE
RUSSIAN INTERFERENCE IN THE
ELECTION.
INTERFERENCE THAT IS CONTINUING
TO THIS DAY, HE SAID.
A LOT OF BACK-AND-FORTH ABOUT
WHAT AUTHORITY HE'S BEEN GIVEN
BY THE PRESIDENT TO IT.
LET'S BRING IN THE PANEL.
FROM WASHINGTON, CHARLES HURT,
OPENING EDITOR FOR
"THE WASHINGTON TIMES."
ELI LAKE, COLUMNIST FOR
BLOOMBERG VIEW.
MARA LIASSON, NATIONAL POLITICAL
CORRESPONDENT AT NATIONAL PUBLIC
RADIO.
A COUPLE EYEBROW-RAISING MOMENTS
TODAY.
>> A LOT OF THEM.
IT'S INCREDIBLE THAT THE HEAD OF
CYBER COMMAND IS SAYING NOT
ENOUGH HAS BEEN DONE AND HE
HASN'T BEEN GIVING THE AUTHORITY
TO DO WHAT HE NEEDS TO DO TO
COUNTER RUSSIAN ATTEMPTS TO
MEDDLE IN THE UPCOMING ELECTION.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT THE 2018
ELECTION.
DIRECTLY CONTRADICTING THE
WHITE HOUSE MESSAGE WHICH IS WE
ARE DOING PLENTY.
>> Bret: HE DID SAY HE WANTED
TO GO INTO CLOSED SESSION AND
TELL YOU WHAT HE WAS DOING.
>> THEY ARE NOT DOING NOTHING.
HE SAID THEY ARE NOT DOING
ENOUGH.
>> I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
ADMIRAL ROGERS WAS TALKING ABOUT
ATTACKING SOME OF THESE THINGS
AT THE POINT OF ORIGIN.
THAT'S A PRETTY SIGNIFICANT
CYBER ISSUE.
IT'S DIVIDING THIS
ADMINISTRATION AND DIVIDED THE
LAST ADMINISTRATION.
ORIGINALLY THIS WAS SOMETHING
PROPOSED IN 2015 UNDER OBAMA AND
I DIDN'T GET TO THE PRESIDENT'S
DESK BECAUSE IT WAS CONSIDERED
SO CONTROVERSIAL IN OTHER PARTS
OF THE NATIONAL SECURITY STATE.
THERE ARE GOOD-FAITH ARGUMENTS
FOR FOR WHY DON'T NECESSARILY
WANT TO ESCALATE IN CYBERSPACE
WITH THE RUSSIANS UNTIL YOU KNOW
EXACTLY HOW TO RESPOND.
>> Bret: ANOTHER EXCHANGE,
CHARLIE, SENATOR BLUMENTHAL.
>> I UNDERSTAND YOUR FEELING IS
YOU HAVE NOT BEEN GIVEN
AUTHORITY TO TAKE ADDITIONAL
ACTION.
HAVE YOU ASKED THAT AUTHORITY?
>> NO, I HAVE NOT.
I HAVE TRIED TO ACT WITHIN THE
AUTHORITY GRANTED TO ME.
>> WHY HAVE YOU NOT ASKED FOR
ADDITIONAL AUTHORITY?
>> I AM NOT SURE THE
CAPABILITIES I HAVE WOULD BE
OPTIMAL OR THE ONLY RESPONSE.
>> WOULDN'T YOU AGREE IT'S AN
UNNECESSARY RESPONSE?
>> IT COULD BE PART OF A
RESPONSE.
I WOULD ACKNOWLEDGE THAT.
I THINK WE NEED TO STEP BACK AND
LOOK AT THIS VERY BROADLY.
>> Bret: THE BOTTOM LINE FROM
THIS HEARING, CHARLIE, IT'S
CONTINUING.
RUSSIA IS CONTINUING TO TRY TO
INTERFERE.
IT HAS DONE IT FOR DECADES BUT
IT'S DOING IT IN AN AGGRESSIVE
MANNER IN CYBERSPACE NOW.
>> YEAH, AND IT'S OBVIOUSLY A
VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE THAT I
THINK WE HAVE HEARD A LOT OF
REPUBLICANS AND EVEN
DONALD TRUMP TALK ABOUT THE NEED
TO DO NOTHING ABOUT IT.
AND THE NEED TO COMBAT IT.
HOW UNFORTUNATE WAS THAT THE
PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATION FAILED
TO COMBAT IT.
I GOT A LITTLE BIT WORN OUT
LISTENING TO PEOPLE LIKE
BLUMENTHAL TALK ABOUT THIS IN
PARTISAN TERMS OR ELIZABETH
WARREN TALKING ABOUT IN PARTISAN
TERMS.
PART OF THE PROBLEM WITH THIS
ENTIRE THING IS THE FACT THAT
IT'S BEEN SO UTTERLY
POLITICIZED.
IT'S NOT ABOUT RUSSIA PER SE OR
VLADIMIR PUTIN PER SE.
IT'S ALL ABOUT DONALD TRUMP.
THEY ARE USING THE INVESTIGATION
IN ORDER TO PUNISH A POLITICAL
OPPONENT.
I THINK THAT'S PROBABLY NOT THE
HEALTHIEST WAY TO GO FORWARD,
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU STEP BACK
AND LOOK AT WHAT HAS BEEN
PRESENTED SO FAR FROM THE
MUELLER INVESTIGATION.
THAT IS, NO REAL EVIDENCE THERE
WAS ANY COLLUSION ON THE PART OF
DONALD TRUMP, THE PRESIDENTIAL
CAMPAIGN, TO COLLUDE WITH THE
RUSSIANS TO TILT THE ELECTION.
>> THAT IS NOT WHAT WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT PROTECTING
THE ELECTORAL SYSTEM WITH FUTURE
RUSSIAN IRREVERENCE            E
RUSSIAN IRREVERENCE            F
RUSSIAN IRREVERENCE            R
RUSSIAN IRREVERENCE            S
RUSSIAN IRREVERENCE            T
RUSSIAN IRREVERENCE            O
RUSSIAN IRREVERENCE            M
RUSSIAN IRREVERENCE            T
RUSSIAN IRREVERENCE            L
RUSSIAN IRREVERENCE            .
THERE'S ALL SORTS OF THINGS THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION CAN DO.
HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH ROBERT
MUELLER OR COLLUSION.
>> THAT'S GREAT AND THOSE ARE
ARE THINGS REPUBLICANS HAVE SAID
THEY WANT TO SEE DONE BUT MY
SIMPLE POINT WAS WHEN YOU START
BY POLITICIZING IT AND USING IT
AS A CUDGEL TO BEAT UP
DONALD TRUMP ALL DAY LONG, IT
LOSES THE BIPARTISAN EFFECT THAT
WE WOULD LIKE.
>> Bret: IN THE MEANTIME,
THERE IS A SECURITY CLEARANCE
QUESTION HERE AT THE
WHITE HOUSE, AND A DECISION WAS
MADE LAST WEEK TO TAKE JARED
KUSHNER FROM TOP-SECRET TO
SECRET CLEARANCE, EVEN AS HE IS
DEALING WITH BIG THINGS LIKE THE
MIDDLE EAST PEACE.
TAKE A LISTEN TO THE PRESIDENT
FRIDAY.
KELLYANNE CONWAY TONIGHT.
>> YORK CHIEF OF STAFF
GENERAL KELLY HAS RECOMMENDED
ENDING THE PRACTICE OF GRANTING
INTERIM SECURITY CLEARANCES TO
MEMBERS OF THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
IF THAT PROCEEDS, WOULD YOU BE
WILLING TO GRANT A WAIVER TO
JARED KUSHNER, ONE OF YOUR
SENIOR ADVISORS?
>> THAT WILL BE UP TO
GENERAL KELLY.
GENERAL KELLY RESPECTS JARED A
LOT AND HE WILL MAKE THAT CALL.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP ON FRIDAY IN
THE PRESS CONFERENCE WITH THE
AUSTRALIAN PRIME MINISTER SAID
HE HAS GREAT FAITH IN JARED
KUSHNER AS A SENIOR ADVISOR TO
CONTINUE TO WORK ON MATTERS
AFFECTING MIDDLE EAST PEACE.
>> Bret: THE WHITE HOUSE
SAYING NOT -- NOT REALLY SAYING
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN DOWN THE
ROAD.
THERE IS A "WASHINGTON POST"
STORY SUGGESTING THERE'S
COUNTRIES THAT TRIED TO USE
FINANCIAL DISCLOSURE ISSUES WITH
JARED KUSHNER AND OTHER
QUESTIONS TO TRY TO INFLUENCE
HIM.
YOUR THOUGHTS ON THE STORY,
WHERE IT IS HEADING AND WHAT
HAPPENS.
>> I THINK THIS GOES BACK TO ONE
OF THE GREATEST VULNERABILITIES
OF THE TRUMP WHITE HOUSE.
THE FAILURE OF THE PRESIDENT TO
SEPARATE HIMSELF FULLY AS
PRESIDENT FROM THE TRUMP
ORGANIZATION.
ALL THE APPEARANCE OF CONFLICTS.
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT IS
AFFECTING JARED KUSHNER RIGHT
NOW.
WE DON'T KNOW EXACTLY WHAT THE
FBI HAS THAT HAS HELD UP ITS
CLEARANCE BUT I WOULD BE WILLING
TO BET IT'S BECAUSE OF JARED
KUSHNER'S OTHER CAREER IN
REAL ESTATE AND OTHER THINGS
THAT HAVE MADE HIM ENTANGLED
WITH OTHER COUNTRIES THAT HE'S
MAYBE HAVING TO DEAL WITH.
THAT IS SOMETHING I THINK HE IS
GOING TO REALLY BE PROBABLY MORE
DAMAGING TO THIS WHITE HOUSE,
THE ISSUE OF SEPARATING THE
PRIVATE BUSINESS FROM THE
COLLUSION STUFF.
WE WILL SEE WHAT COMES OF IT.
>> Bret: WE SHOULD POINT OUT
IT'S POSSIBLE THIS CLEARANCE
DOES COME THROUGH, WHETHER IT
TAKES A WEEK OR TWO.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THE HOLDUP IS
OR WHETHER IT'S NOT GOING TO
COME THROUGH.
MARA, LAST WORD ABOUT
CLEARANCES.
>> IT'S BEEN ALMOST A YEAR.
JARED KUSHNER SATA AMEND HIS
SECURITY CLEARANCE FORM MANY
TIMES.
IN PREVIOUS WHITE HOUSES, HAVING
TO AMEND IT WOULD BE A REASON TO
DENY YOU THE CLEARANCE.
RIGHT NOW HE'S BEEN DOWNGRADED
TO SECRET.
THAT MEANS HE CAN'T READ THE
DAILY BREEZE.
HE CAN'T HAVE ACCESS TO HIGHLY
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION.
HE HAS A VERY BROAD PORTFOLIO.
MIDDLE EAST PEACE, CHINA, MEXICO
MIDDLE EAST PEACE, CHINA, MEXIC
MEXICO.
>> Bret: A LOT OF CLASSIFIED